Yarn color for each finger.
Council members in attendance council member abby cayman
district c council member carolyn evan shabaz district d council member
tiffany d. Thomas district f vice chair ed
pollard district j Council Member Michael Kubosh
at large position three council member staff from Council Member Leticia
Plumber's office, staff from Council Member Mike Knox's
office and staff from Council Member Mary NAN Huffman's office.
All budget workshops will be conducted in person. Only public
speakers have the option to come in in person or virtually 48 hours prior
to the start of all workshops. Presentation materials are uploaded
to SharePoint and hard copies delivered to each council office.
Our departments have been directed to provide written responses within
48 hours of the conclusion of their presentation to any questions
posted by council members to SharePoint. The budget workshop schedule
is posted on the BFA website. Questions from council
members can be uploaded at any time during the budget workshop
process, the earlier the better, allowing the departments plenty of
time to provide responses. All public speakers should be
signed up to speak. If you have not signed up, please sign
up at the front table. My staff, Carolina, will be monitoring
the public speakers list. The 2023
budget amendment template has also been uploaded to SharePoint. Mayor Turner
sent out a memo to all council members and council offices to ensure
a productive discussion on the 23 proposed budget.
Amendments are due Wednesday, May 25.
Again, amendments to the budget are due Wednesday,
May 25. The agenda.
Today we'll hear from Public Works, Department of Neighborhoods,
It, Human Resources, Office of Business Opportunity,
Fleet Management, Housing Department and Houston Public Libraries.
As a reminder, only people attend in virtual or public speakers.
There are six virtual speakers signed up for public comment to speak,
and there are 13 people virtually
joining us. And we'll get their questions after the presentations
and questions from council members have been concluded.
I would like to welcome council member Sally
Alcorn at large position five, and staff
from Carlos Cisnero's office, council District H.
At this time, I'd like to welcome Director Carol Haddock and Mr.
Samir Salanki and to provide the public Works department's
update And Happy Public Works Week.
All right, thank you very much.
Good morning, everybody. Today we're here to discuss the fiscal
year 2023 budget for Houston Public Works. My name
is Carol Haddock, director of Houston Public Works. And I'm joined by my colleague,
Samir Solanki, chief financial officer for Houston Public Works. We have
other members of the Houston Public Works executive team
and also our budget team that have joined us in this meeting so that
we may answer questions on the spot if you may have them.
Next slide, please. Oh, wait, you're already at the next slide.
Houston Public Works aims to abide by our purpose and our five
to thrive values in all that we do. Together, we create a
strong foundation for Houston to thrive, and we do this every day by
doing the things that most people don't see or notice unless something
goes wrong. And we take great pride in that. We embody
our five to thrive values every day. We operate through integrity,
through teamwork. We take ownership of things we're responsible for.
We strive to communicate and we look for respect,
starting with ourselves, our colleagues, the citizens we
serve, this body and ultimately the city of Houston itself.
Next slide, please.
Houston Public Works Executive Teams consists of the capable
people that you see on this slide. At the end of this presentation,
there is a very extensive appendix. It shows all of our
accomplishments for fiscal year 2022, even though it's not
over yet. And while I would love to talk about our accomplishments, I am
going to skip that today and leave that for you to look at at the
back of the presentation. So please do take the time to
look through that as you go through it. Next slides,
please, for what you see on a day to day basis.
Our operational service lines, our five service lines that provide
the services. Our capital projects, customer account services,
houston Permitting Center, houston Water and Transportation and Drainage
operations. These service lines don't have a single cost
fund center. They actually have multiple funds, and most of them have
multiple cost centers. We have a long presentation
and I am going to hand this over to Samir Solanki to discuss the budget
for Houston Public Works at this time. Samir?
Thank you, Carol. Next slide, please.
Like Carol mentioned, this is a pretty significant presentation. We'll do our best
to try to get through all the information in the time that's allotted.
Like Carol had mentioned, public Works consists of several funds and this
slide summarizes the changes in revenues and expenditures from fiscal
year 2022 for each of these funds. I'm not going to
call out each of these numbers as we'll cover all of this in detail in
the upcoming slides. Please keep in mind that the variances are from the
FY 22 current budget. And because this is rolled slide,
these numbers are in millions. Once we get to each of the fund, we'll be
talking in thousands. Next slide, please.
First, we'll begin by discussing the General Fund.
Okay, there we go. Now, this is just an overview of
the major services requirements, impact and population served by
the General Fund within the Houston Public Works Department. Let's dig
a little deeper. The requirements for this service delivery.
Let me skip that part. Let's go to the next slide.
There we go. These are the revenue overviews.
For the revenue portion, a small amount is brought in from recoveries and refunds,
and majority of this is from sale of capital assets. Recoveries and
refunds are from the recovery of electricity costs for decorative lighting
that's above the city standard. Something like closer between
poles or higher wattage bulbs, which the city has paid to
CenterPoint and bills back to the corresponding management districts who request
the above standard lighting. Next slide,
please. The majority of
services for this portion of the General Fund is related to electricity for traffic
signals and street lights citywide, which is considered a restricted account
with no budgeted FTEs. The Real Estate Management section
generates revenue for the General Fund by selling property and easements throughout
the Houston area, and this is accomplished by nine positions within
this fund. This section is also responsible for management
of Houston Public Works real estate inventory, including oversight
and management of city owned property interest such as streets,
easements, alleys and fee owned land and the process requests
for encroachment into streets or alleys through the Joint Referral Committee
process, the JRC process. Next slide,
please. Now we'll take
a look at the expenditures and this is a further breakdown of these expenditures
for the General Fund. The General Fund's largest expense consists
of the restricted accounts that I'd mentioned previously, which include service chargebacks
for fuels, electricity, It accounts and other items.
The projected budget for electricity in this fund is 21.4 million
due to transitioning from a floating rate to a locked in
electricity rate. Next slide, please.
Now, this chart is broken out by personnel and nonpersonal
items, and you'll notice that the largest amount is made up of restricted
accounts, that is primarily electricity, which is at 21.4
million, and the It hits restricted accounts for about 300,000.
Next slide, please.
The Net Change slide walks through the items that contribute to
the increase in expenditures for the Houston Public Works portion of the
General Fund. The operating budget decreased slightly in supplies
based on spending trends as compared to fiscal year 22.
There were increases in contractual or mandated adjustments for restricted accounts
and interference services of about 700,000, as well as
17,000 increase in hope and benefit rates, which resulted
in an overall increase of 3.3% in the fiscal year 2023
budget. Next slide, please.
Now let's move on to the project cost recovery fund.
This slide provides an overview of the major services, requirements,
impacts and populations served by the Project Cost Recovery Fund.
This is a revolving fund and it derives its revenues from different funds
within Houston Public Works, which means that whatever revenues are brought
in must be fully expended.
Next slide. Got it. The Project Cost Recovery Fund
revenues are increasing from 51.9 million
to 55.7 million, for about a difference of 3.8
million. The project cost recovery fund expenses are increasing.
Excuse me. 2.8 million of this is due to increase in hope
and benefits, and the remaining increases are in restricted accounts,
interfund services and building maintenance.
Next slide, please.
And this is a program organizational chart which I'll go through individually.
The transportation and drainage Operations manages and analyzes traffic
calming patterns, collects data coordinates with regional partners
to develop transportation and drainage projects. The office of
the Director administers the city's MWD program.
Then we have Houston Water, which manages contractual issues and other
required coordination related to the Northeast water purification
plant expansion. Then we have Financial Management Services that
processes the pay estimates and project reimbursements, provides financial
reports on project and grant related activities,
monitors and accounts for CIP related revenues and expenses.
Then we have Capital Projects, which is responsible for the
implementation of engineering and construction of infrastructure projects for
the City's adopted five year CIP plan.
Then there's also Information Technology, which provides and maintains technology
solutions to support planning, design, construction, operation and maintenance
of the public infrastructure systems, and also technically assists
the Houston Public Work inspectors to perform work and input data
into Cipms from remote sites. Then the managed support.
Finally, the Managed and Support Branch provides necessary funding to ensure
effective delivery of accurate, reliable and timely biweekly payroll
reports. Next slide please.
And this chart shows a breakdown between the personnel and
non personnel. The total budget proposed is 55.7
million. Of that, the personal accounts for 45
million. Next slide please.
Now we move on to the building inspection fund, which is
also the Houston Permitting Center.
The major services is to ensure buildings and structures adhere to
City of Houston's Building Code, as well as review and approve commercial
and residential development plans for the City's infrastructure.
The impact is safety, usability and sustainability of
the private and publicly built environment. Next slide,
please.
The Building Inspection Fund of revenues are increasing from 84.4
million up to 91.0 million for a 6.7
million increase due to more anticipated permitting and
construction activity and annual CPI increase in
fees. The expenditures are decreasing from 103,000,000
to 102.5 million, mainly due to reduction
in the fiscal 23 for the design and development of the
new permitting and inspection system and decreasing in land and
building costs for joint parking garage with HPD.
And this is offset by the increase in personal costs and restricted budgets.
Next slide please.
And this is the program organizational chart for the Building Inspection Fund
and for the Office of the Director. We have the Mayor's Office for
people with Disabilities, serves as the primary advocate for
the rights and needs of citizens with disabilities, serves as a
liaison between the Mayor, City Council, city Departments and other public and private entities.
Then the Houston Permitting Center, which performs a regulatory role to
ensure the safety, usability and sustainability of private and
public built environment. Then also the practical application of
reviews, permanent permit administration and field inspection
for building codes, sign administration and public infrastructure.
Then we have Information Technology that provides the highest quality technology
based services in the most effective and cost effective manner.
Then we have the Management Support Branch, which provides necessary funding
for the Building Inspection biweekly payroll function.
Next slide, please.
The total proposed budget is 102.5 million. Of that,
personnel accounts for around 70.8 million. The nonpersonal
budget is around 31.6 million. 5.4 million is
for the Hue permit system, 5.9 million is for
the HPC support and 4.3 is for HPC,
It and supplies and services. Restricted accounts consist
mainly of hits restricted accounts, which is 2.7 million.
Houston Public Works indirect costs of 2.3 million,
citywide indirect costs of 1.6 million.
Fleet restricted accounts, which is 1 million and payroll restricted accounts of about
1 million. Then the building code enforcement of 3.1
million is broken down into 1.5 million of consulting services
to assist the city in residential and commercial brand review and inspection
in citywide developments, with the remaining 2.3 million going towards
vehicles and other services. Next slide,
please.
Let's keep going. Transportation and Drainage something got off here.
All right. Transportation and Drainage, which contains funds
23 223, 1020,
311 and 20 312. Funds 23 1020
311 and 20 312 comprise of the Build Houston Forward
Program. These funds were previously all held in 23
ten and were split into three funds in fiscal year 2021.
Pause for just a moment. The presentation appears to have disappeared from the
screens.
We have an It issue, as you recognize, so please follow
along on your printed copies if you have them at your disposal.
Okay, thanks. 24.
Okay, we're on slide number 24.
The major services provided are to maintain and operate street
and drainage systems, to plan for reinvestment of infrastructure
and growth needs for the City of Houston, and to coordinate with outside entities
for impacts to city infrastructure and uses. The impacts affect
neighborhood drainage, subregional or drainage, and detention and citywide
mobility. Next slide.
This is the overview of the revenues for the transportation and drainage operations.
The Stormwater Fund, which is 23 two revenues
are decreasing by 3.3 million, and this is due to about 5.8
million less transfer needed from the combined utility system to cover
operations and maintenance. And this is offset by an increase in transfer from the
drainage charge from Fund 23 ten by 2 million.
Fund 23 ten. Revenues are increasing by 400,000
due to higher projected amount of interest earned compared to fiscal
year 22.
The Advalorum Tax Fund 20 311 revenues
are increasing by 2.1 million, mainly due to 1.7 million
additional tax revenues projected to transfer in from
the General Fund, as well as 400,000 higher projected amount
of interest earned compared to fiscal year 2022.
The Metro Etol Fund 20 312 is mostly flat,
increasing mainly due to 550,000
increase in Interfront revenues for potential work performed
by transportation and drainage operations for other Houston
Public Service Lines or other city departments, as well as 315,000
for expected reimbursements under the Metro General Mobility Program.
Next slide, please.
And this is the transportation and drainage expenditures.
On the expenditure side, the Stormwater Fund is decreasing by
1.5 million due to lower operating costs,
which is about 2,000,002.6 million, restricted budgets of about
300,000 and capital rollovers of 600,000.
This is offset by an increase in personnel costs of about
2 million. The Ddsrf Funds group
are increasing by 6.2 million due to a 6.9 million
increase in transfers to CIP, which is offset
by a 500,000 decrease in supplies.
Keeping in mind that 22 to 23 1020 311
20 312 make up the Ddsr Funds group. Next slide.
Where are we? There we go.
We are on slide number 27, Stormwater Fund 23
two, the program organizational chart,
the transportation and drainage operations responsible for
inspecting, cleaning and repairing current storm sewer infrastructure.
The Financial Management Services manages payment of the principal and interest
on stormwater debt and pension obligation bond debt.
The Houston Permitting Center maintains and administers the city's Texas Pollution
Discharge Elimination System. The TPDES Stormwater Permit
Information Technology provides the highest quality technology based
service in the most effective and cost effective manner. And then Management Support Branch
provides training related to various safety practices, safety awareness
initiatives, and acts as a liaison between Division and
certain state and local agencies. Next slide,
please.
Man that's 28.
Yeah, 28. I think I just went through Tammy. There was yep.
Then the Ddsrf drainage charge fund 23 ten.
The office of this is again the program organizational charge.
Slide 28. We have the Chief Recovery Office liaisons
with governments and other organizations to reduce flooding risk.
Mission is to ensure a rapid quality recovery from Hurricane Harvey
and other disasters and position the city to be less vulnerable to the
next record breaking storm. It also helps identify transformative
projects and design strategies for mitigating flood risk and achieving
flood resiliency. Then we have Financial Management Services, which manages
funding for various items such as transfer for Stormwater
and the Capital Improvement projects. Management Support Branch
provides necessary funding to ensure accurate, reliable and
timely biweekly payroll reports and then Customer Account Services,
which provides billing and customer service to drainage utility customers.
Next slide please. Slide 29.
The Ddsrf Advalorum Tax Fund 20 311,
which includes transportation and drainage operation, which is responsible for
maintenance of streets and bridges installation,
operation and maintenance of the traffic signal system.
Installation of maintenance of traffic control signs,
pavement markings and flashing school beacons maintenance of
roadway lighting on major highways conduct studies involving speed
zones and traffic counts review of street lined installations.
Then the Financial Management Services branch manages fund
transfer for CIP projects and 380 agreements.
Next slide please. Slide 30. Ddsrf Metro
Etol program organizational chart of Which A
transportation and drainage operation is Responsible for maintenance of Streets and bridges,
installation operation, maintenance of the traffic signal system,
installation and Maintenance of the traffic control signs, pavement markings and
flashing School beacons. Maintenance of roadway lighting for what
I had just mentioned previously is also part of the 20 312 Information
Technology. Provides help desk, desktop application work management system
support along With Other System Support. The Management
Support Services Branch provides necessary funding to ensure
effective delivery of professional services related to employee health and safety
response support in emergencies created by natural or manmade disasters,
spill response contract compliance, accident and injury
investigations and field surveys, and inspections and also ensures
accurate, reliable and timely biweekly payroll reports.
Next slide please. Slide 31.
It looks like we're back. All right. The total purpose proposed budgets
is 390,000,000, of which personal accounts for around
71.6 million and non personal accounts for around 318,000,000.
The cash transfer is related to capital projects expenditures account
capital projects expenditures account for a bulk of it and the remaining
items are related to operations and maintenance expense for street
traffic and drainage related items. Debt services is mostly
comprised of retiring the pre 2012 public
Improvement bond debt in 23 two which the principal balance is about
18.8 million.
Next slide please.
Sure. The last part, the debt service is mostly comprised
of retiring the pre 2012 public Improvement
bond debt in 23 two which the principal balance is
about 18.8 billion. Next slide please. We're on slide 32.
Moving on to TranStar. Next slide.
There we go. TranStar is a
collaborative program between the city, Harris County,
Metro and the Texas Department of Transportation that provides transportation,
homeland security and emergency management for city
and 13 surrounding counties. Next slide please.
Slide 34. On the revenue side,
the decrease is due to the reducing grant contributions
from Metro. Metro reduced contributions by 527,000
due to Metro's takeover of the maintenance and upkeep of TranStar
Center from GSD. The increase in contribution from the city of
Houston and Harris County is about 76,000. On the expenditure
side, personnel and land and ground maintenance services are the
main drivers for the increase. Then also the increase is also due
to hope, pension, health insurance and land
and other ground maintenance costs. Next slide please. Slide number
34 five. Excuse me.
The Traffic Operations division which includes about ten
FTEs. That manages, operates and maintains a heat and transfer system.
Next slide please.
The proposed budget is 3.4 million of which nonpersonal
accounts for 2 million. The breakout is the operations
and maintenance accounts for 1.7 million which consists of 575,000
for construction site work services for about 400,000 for
building maintenance, 150,000 for advertising,
about 100,000 for contingency and 400,000 for various
other services and supplies. The other remaining 373,000
belong to restricted accounts which includes electricity,
hits and then fleet, payroll and utilities accounts.
Next slide please.
Finally, we move on to
the biggest enterprise fund which is the combined utility system, the largest
fund group within Houston Public Works.
The major services for the utility are production and distribution of
over 146,000,000,000 gallons of water,
treatment of 90 billion gallons of wastewater and billing and collection for
480,000 water and wastewater accounts.
Next slide please.
The revenue highlights include in fund 8300.
They're increasing mainly due to 280,000,000 water and sewer
rate increase adopted by council via ordinance
2021 five one five fund
83 one. There is a 5.7 million decrease in scheduled
debt service payments then fund 83 five is
the combined utility system savings account and doesn't typically
generate revenue. However, in fiscal year 2021
we had a $9.4 million increase due
to water authorities contribution for the lease value payment
which is about 9.4 or 9.5 million.
Next slide please.
The expenditure highlights include the following for fund 8300,
there is an increase of 43.3 million increase in operations
and maintenance costs. And this is broken down into various
categories which include about 9.5 million in chemicals
and gas, 3.3 million management consulting services,
1.1 miscellaneous support services,
8.1 million in equipment services,
2.3 million in construction site work services, 4.8 million
in river authority contracts, 1.2 million in computer
software, 2.8 million increases in the consent decrease stipulated
penalties 4.2 million increase in building maintenance services,
2.1 million increase in intrafund electricity
maintenance, 1 million Interfront application services,
1.8 million in system debt service transfer,
and 1 million in non capital office expenditures.
There's also a 19 million increase in personnel due to hope and
benefits rate changes and a 2.3 decrease in debt
service transfers. For 83,
one, there is a 5.8 million in system debt services payment.
Then for Fund 83 five, we have
an increase in the pay go, which is the pay as you go service,
the cash funding for the CIP portion. Then 11.7
million increase in capital equipment including new and rollovers,
4.7 million increase for meter replacement program and
1.5 million increase for McKinney building maintenance and improvements
and 800,000 increase for Water Authority contract debt
and then a 4.8 million reduction in transfer to
Stormwater. Now, a quick note that we are purposely
making the decision to increase our cash funding or the pay
go funding for the combined utility system CIP so we can cash
on projects instead of debt financing given the current market environment
that has high inflation and also with the rising interest rates.
Next slide, please.
This is the program organizational chart for the Water and Sewer
Operating Fund 8300 office of the Director provides leadership
and oversight in the operations for the Houston Public Works Department.
Houston Water produces and supplies portable drinking
water throughout the Harris County and portions of the surrounding counties.
Financial Management manages, monitors and controls department's financial and
accounting activities capital projects initiates and
manages the sale of surplus utility owned properties. It implements,
installs, configures, supports and maintains Houston
Public Works computer software, telecommunications and software such
as SCADA, WiMAX, Network and Security Systems management
support Branch provides support in the areas of records management,
fleet support and internal review. Now we have
Customer Account Services which reads maintains water sewer
meters, produces the bills, receives and processes
invoice payments, manages credit and collections processes and responds
to billing inquiries. Next slide, please.
The combined utility system total proposed budget is 1.6
billion for fiscal year 2023, of which
personnel accounts for 234,000,000 and non personnel
budget is one point rounded up to 1.4 billion.
The nonpersonal section consists of the following
$583,000,000 is for debt service 285,000,000
water and wastewater operations, 51 million transfer to
Stormwater and 300 million for the pay as you
go for the cash funding for the CIP. Next slide,
please.
Then this is the combined utility system revenues,
expenditures, and this sort of gives you a net overview. And if
you please note that in fiscal year 22 and fiscal year 23,
the combined utility system is showing a budgetary deficit,
which the combined utility system is intentionally spending down its
fund balance. Next slide,
please. That concludes the
Houston Public Works Budget presentation. We're open to any questions.
Thank you very much. We have a number of council members in queue. And first
of all, thank you for skinnying this down. When I saw
20 public speakers, I knew we had to do a little bit of an audible.
So thank you, directors. Appreciate that. Council Member Michael Kubosh.
Thank you very much. I noticed on page 40 you talked about that's the
first time I heard the word consent decree. Have we had any breaches
of the consent decree?
Would you mind repeating the question? The wastewater.
Have we had any breaches since we've actually signed the consent decree?
So we have continued to have some sanitary sewer overflows
that. Part of signing the consent decree is an
agreed plan to invest and reduce those over
time. There's a recognition when you sign the consent decree that it's
not going to magically stop. So we have continued to
have some, but we are doing better. We are seeing significant
reductions with the increased cleaning and televising that is already
happening. Let me ask you concerning the defect. I get reports
of defective water meters. One of the biggest complaints I get is the fact
that we have water bills, that citizens
are trying to contest their water bills.
Have we determined what percentage of the
water meters are defective and what the citizens
do? So let me jump in real quick.
It is very rare for an actual water meter to be defective.
What we are seeing is the remote reader that attaches
to the water meter. They are 20 years old and they are dying
every day. And so what happens is, we have months where we
estimate, because we didn't get a good read, but the meters themselves,
it's very rare for one to be defective. Ways to test them.
Well, if the device that's attached to it, that's reading it is
defective, are getting old, then the citizen would consider
that a defective water meter because they see it as
all encapsulated. As one thing.
How do we buy fuel, gasoline,
gasoline, and diesel and CNG?
Do we purchase it in an annual basis,
or do we have contracts? How do we get our fuel?
So I'm going to defer that to fleet, as that is not public
works purchasing separately. It is a citywide contract.
Thank you very much. Put me back in the queue, sir. Council Member
Vice Chair Ed Pollard. Thank you,
Chair, and good morning to everyone. Thank you for the presentation.
My questions are regarding permitting from
a financial standpoint. What are some processes or
systems that we can put in place or that we have put in place
to streamline expedite, speed up the permitting
process. So we recently gave a presentation
to TTI about some of the improvements and processes
that are happening internally. Some of the biggest things that we've done
is provide an opportunity for the same reviewer to review the
plan set on a subsequent submittal. But we've
also augmented our capacity by
executing outside contracts that allow us, when our capacity
exceeds our personnel resources, to use some of those outside
resources. We're still working to
catch up and get on top of it. We admit that we are longer than
we need to be, but we do believe that we have the tools in
place to eat down the backlog and keep up moving forward. So when
you say that, you know that we're kind of behind, but we're doing what we
can to catch up, are there benchmarks
in place or a strategy in place
to show that, okay, we know we need to get here, here's how we're
going to do it. So yes, sir. And that's
part of what was presented at TTI just recently. I would be happy
it is available on the website. I'm council member.
We'll provide that information, but we'll be happy to provide you some
additional information on that. Okay? And can we jump to page 25 really quick,
Director? It might be good to get a date of that meeting if your staff
is able to help us with that for the Council member.
Everybody doesn't watch those.
Yes, sir. Page 25. Page 20.
Go ahead. Page 25. If we can pull it up
on the screen. There was a for
stormwater. We're showing a 4.8%
decrease change from variance from fiscal
year 22 to now. Can you further elaborate on that?
Trying to find where you're looking at the 4.8 million. I'm seeing a 5.8
million less transfer. I see the stormwater revenues,
is that what you're talking about? Not the top line. Right. So the, the revenues
are decreasing by 3.3 million. This is due to $5.8
million less transfer needed from the combined utility system
to cover operations and maintenance cost. That's what it's due to.
And it's offset by an increase in
transfer from 23 ten. So stormwater gets its funding from two
areas. One is Ddsr of 23 ten, and the bulk of
the funding comes from the combined utility system. And so this year there was
a lesser need and then a little bit of an increase funding from
the Ddsrf funds group. So it nets out to about a
3.3 million decrease in the funding that was needed for Saltwater. But there is
adequate funding for it, in your opinion?
Yes, adequate funding. Absolutely. Thank you.
Before we go to council member Sally Alcorn, we've been joined by
council members Amy Peck, Tarsha Jackson,
Mary Anne Huffman, vice Mayor Pro TEM Martha Castex Tatum
and Chairman David Robinson. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you for your presentation. In the Ddsrf
drainage fee revenue, I noticed that we
budgeted last year like $113,000,000
in revenue. We ended up getting more than that, about 126 or
28 million, and then we're budgeting back down at 113.
Is there a reason that we had that increase last year and over what
we thought? And why aren't we expecting it? Again,
some of these revenues, it depends on projections,
and again, we look at it from a fund perspective. So you're budgeting more conservatively
on revenues. That's what we try to do. Just we don't want to overestimate.
Okay, thank you. And in the Ddsrf,
advalorum transferred from
the general fund was about 77 million, plan about 77 million.
We're advancing about 97 million to capital projects.
I'm assuming some of that's coming from from fund balance. From from fund balance,
yes. When we get the transfer from the general fund to that
fund, that is less what's paid down in debt service.
That's done before you get the transfer? That's correct. That is debt service prior to
do you know how much debt has been paid down from
Advalorum since Rebuild Houston started? The amount
of debt that we paid off so far has been about and let me have
that information here.
Let me bring that's
1.5 billion that's been paid, and we have about 905,000,000.
That's $1.5 billion in debt. And that is
a major thing because that's what let us borrow for pension
obligation bonds. I mean, that the reduction in debt was a big part
in letting us borrow more money. So that's an important feature on
the building Inspection fund. And that presentation was done in November
4 of last year on permitting.
So we're due for an update, and Council Member Robinson and I will be hosting
an event on permitting. And put me back in the queue.
Council Member Michael Kubash. Thank you very much.
Once again, the number of complaints that I
receive each week deal with either water
problems, either leaks, or the customer
feels overbuilt, and the other is
permitting. Permitting.
The citizens just shouldn't have to hire
an expediter to get a permit done.
And I don't know what your role
is on trying to get this permitting done properly,
but I know that we passed, during the Parker administration,
right before she left, we passed an ordinance that allowed
the permit fees to go into a separate fund.
Is that still happening? So the permitting
fund that we briefed today is a special revenue
fund within the general fund that was created during that time. So it is
a subset of the general fund, but it
is somewhat firewalled off in the sense that the fees
generated by permit fees stay in that fund and are used for the expenses
in that fund. Well, the whole purpose for permitting is for public safety
and not for necessarily revenue gathering. But I
do want to say that we
definitely need some help there. How much money
did the Public Works apply for ARPA funds
or cares dollars from the federal government on COVID-19?
Separate that is, separate from this budget hearing,
and we're happy to provide that to you separately and offline.
We worked with the citywide processes for both ARPA and
COVID and within the city's priorities. We did
receive funding in both of those categories to support activities within
the department, but that is not included
in this presentation as we were directed. Well, I would sure like to have that
sent to me. Would you do that? Yes.
No, absolutely, yes. I mean, the City of Houston received
ARPA funds and it was subdivided into each and every
department within the city. I'm not sure what your allocation is that correct?
Yes, that is correct. Thank you,
Council Member Tiffany Thomas. Thank you,
Mayor Pro. Tim, you went through the presentation fairly quickly, so can
you clarify some points to me and just give me context for the divisions
that have a substantial budget but zero FTE?
So, for example, if we go to page 27
stormwater Fund, the Management Support Branch,
it's 296,000,000, but there's zero FTE.
Can you just clarify why
it's a chargeback? Yes, I believe that's a citywide
chargeback that comes back to us that we pay.
And is that the same train of thought for all divisions that
might have substantial budget, certain C TOI processes that
we pay for that get charged back to us? Got it. Thank you much.
Follow up by Council Member Michael Kubosh. Can you
tell us where the city of Houston rates
in major cities as far as our water cost that we're charging
our citizens? Have you done a comparison with other cities like
Dallas or Fort Worth or the major Texas cities?
Yes, sir. Last year when we went through the rate study and recommended
updates to City Council, we had several charts that were direct comparisons with
other cities. We were at the bottom of the pile, and now we're still towards
the bottom of the pile. I'm glad to hear that. Thank you very much for
that. I think the citizens need to be aware of that because when they get
their water bills, I'm sure they don't feel that way. And the bottom of the
pile being good, as in we're cheaper. Thank you
very much. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you. Back on the building Inspection fund. And I know that
there are 26 additional FDES coming to
the permitting center over last year.
And that's good because in looking at
the performance measures, we're at 22% of first
reviews for commercial plans in 15 days, but our goal
is to get to 80%. So that's a pretty significant thing. I know we've
done some outsourcing. I know we've got some we have not done any outsourcing.
Not outsourcing. Sorry. Staff augmentation. Very clear about
that. Staff augmentation and
then hiring. And I'll ask these in writing.
I'd like to know specifically. I've got some charts there where the Vacancies
and make sure we're getting those 26 people to the right
places. Primarily, the complaints I hear about on
slow downs are in the office of City Engineer,
so traffic and Storm and to some degree, planning. So that's
where I'd want to see those resources spent.
But I'll have some additional questions in writing, but just wanted to get
that out there that I was happy to see that there were 26. I think
that we have had attrition of over 30 people.
So 26 hopefully brings us back to address the backlog
and go to the future. Thank you. Yes. And make sure we upload those to
SharePoint, as you always. So thank you. Just a quick follow up to
Council Member Kubasha's. Questions related to permitting.
A few months ago, we did a supplement to hire we hired a
firm to supplement the existing employees.
Does that $89 million I'm looking on the expense side include that,
or is that separate? So it is in the
non personnel side of the expenses. So it's not included
in the 89 million I was looking at in the previous page.
Correct. I think I answered my own question.
It's not included. It's a supplement. You also mentioned consent
decree, stipulated penalties. How much do we pay in
stipulated penalties on consent decree?
So the first demand that we had, and I'd be recalling this from memory,
was for 1.2 million. 1.3 million.
And that was for a full year's worth.
We had budgeted about two and a half million when we originally laid this out.
And we're performing better and have lower estimates than that.
So less than 2 million a year. And it will continue to go
down, although the way that the agreement is
written, the stipulated penalties are a lot lower.
Now. When you get to year five and year eight and year ten,
they go up because that's the incentive for you to get the work done.
Got it. So we better get moving. Yes. So on
page slide 40, you had on
C US, 256,000,000 billion dollar
million dollar increase on the variance to the budget
you mentioned. It's pay as you go. Water Authority contract Debt
Is that the Northeast water purification percentage
debt in our percentage of payment,
83 five. What is the increase?
You said pay go water is a
significant portion of it. Previously, we'd done about
$70 million in Pego, but given the current environment,
with the market conditions, we increased that to 300 million. So it's
an additional about 230,000,000. That's a significant portion. But I think what
you're talking about is 800,000, which is a very small amount.
That's increase for Water Authority contractual debt
that previously existed. What bucket do we pay
the Northeast water? Our share of the Northeast water purification plant.
It's part of the total debt services that I had mentioned previously and included
in the $583,000,000 on an annual basis. Council member
Tasha Jackson.
Thank you. Thank you, Director Haddock, for the presentation.
I have one question about the transportation and
drainage operation budget. Does that in any of
that include like a drainage maintenance plan
for neighborhoods that have the open ditches?
Yes, the operation side of that does include the maintenance
of the roadside ditches as part of the activities
within that fund. Okay. Because right now, I know the residents are
like the ditches that's within their neighborhoods. They are required to
maintenance their own drainages and their ditches. And so one
of the things we're trying to push is to get Public Works to conduct
that maintenance because that contributes a lot of the flooding in these neighborhoods.
And so I just wanted to know, was that included? Yes, ma'am. Okay. Thank you,
staff from Council member Abby Cayman's office.
Good morning, everyone. Council Member Cayman first wants to thank Public
Works and the entire team and the Director, of course,
for your leadership and all the work that you guys are doing day
in and day out. There are too many people to think individually right now,
but we recognize not only the budgetary challenges,
but the additional challenge that COVID presented. I know you didn't
go through them, but the list is in the appendix
should be commended. We have a few questions that we will also share and submit
through the SharePoint. But she noticed some divisions
in Red, and that Council
Member came in, has passed on a budget amendment last year
that will possibly help inspections and bring in additional revenue.
Flagging that to see where in the process that is.
Again, we will communicate that question via SharePoint.
The question that Council Member Cayman is asking of each department is due
to the budgetary constraints, including the revenue cap, what needs
exist that we are not able to address through this year's budget?
That's a big question. So within the activities that we
have defined for us, we believe that we have adequate funding
to address if we want to add activities citywide,
that's where we begin to run into challenges. I know there's some requests
for additional maintenance in some areas that we see,
particularly in the storm drainage system. We also see it in our sidewalks.
And so our challenges would be those. But I would
also remind everybody that in street and drainage, in our transportation and
drainage operations, we are limited to 25%
that can be spent on O and M by Ddsrf,
by the charter amendment.
And we are at that 25% with the activities
we have. So additional funding wouldn't necessarily even be available for those activities.
Council member Tiffany Thomas. Thank you. Just to follow up
on that, can you share more about the capital improvement projects
that have been scheduled but not funded? Because I know we have significant
number of capital improvements that are due to neighborhoods.
So in context of having adequate funding, but also the
caveat of that 25%. Could you elaborate on that?
Well, so the capital improvements are not with that 25%
cap. And so the funding that we have available,
we've seen a significant increase in the estimated cost of
those projects. And so everybody's still in line.
It takes longer to serve the line. And so because of the increased
cost, in some cases, the decreased funding we have seen because
of revenue cap less transfer than we had originally projected
on the advilorum side, and that's really what has extended out.
We've also seen a decrease in metro sales tax revenue
that has been transferred as well. So it
is really a struggle. But we have those
projects developed enough to seek the federal funding that
should become available through the infrastructure bill and the IJA.
So we are actively matching projects to
programs as we see the buckets become available to
move those forward, with a big emphasis on looking
for funding those capital projects in our communities
that have historically been underinvested.
And there's no way to skip the line. I'm just asking, can we skip the
line? No.
Last question from council members is Council Member David Robinson. Thank you,
Chair and Director. Thanks for your presentation. I know you've covered a
lot of territory and picking up a little bit where my colleague Tiffany Thomas
just went with Deferred CIP projects and
some of what our chair has inquired about with the biggest ticket
items on water and sewer and the general purpose combined
utility programs. I wanted to get some
territory on the real bottom of that. I know you and I have talked about
the expenditures going to the accessibility program that Director
Casares has taken on, as well as some of what you've described today
with TranStar and other programs. So from
the large budget items to the small, I wonder if you
could just take a second to narrate some of your concerns about the
changes in the budget this year, what we might be looking at,
and anything that we can help you with.
I don't know that I would use concerns. I would say that we definitely have
some opportunities to look back at our activities and make sure that
everything that we're putting our energy effort resources to is the highest priority
for the city. And so as we look at our biggest ones,
our water and wastewater, obviously we're going to be focused on the resilience
and sustainability of the existing systems while
also allowing for that future growth and redevelopment.
And if you bring that through water wastewater, that also includes
street and storm. But on the permitting side, this will be
the year that we really focus on moving towards the
2021 building codes. And so we're going to be really
focused on that forward leaning. What can we do to
make sure that we are setting things in place that administrations
after this one where I'm sitting,
are primed for the future? Yes, and as
you and I have spoken about with that on the queue of things that we're
going to take on, whether that's within a special called meeting in the
June meeting of the TTI committee or as soon as we can
get to it after July 1,
we're going to take that on pending the administration's approval.
So thank you very much, Director. Thank you, Chair.
We'll now move to the public comment section. There are six
virtual public speakers and we have a total of
20 public speakers on the list.
Please, when I announce your name, please hit star six to unmute because we
will have to go rapidly. Our first speaker is Mr. Doug Smith.
1 minute. Each speaker has 1 minute.
Doug Smith.
Mr. Tom Thompson. Star Six. Mr.
Thompson?
Yes. Can you hear me? Is this Mr.
Thompson? That's Doug. Yes, go ahead.
Who do we have? Do we have Tom Thompson?
And this is Doug Smith as well. Do we
have Mr. Thompson?
Yes, go ahead. Do you hear me? Yes, sir, we can.
Okay, thank you.
Do you want Doug to go first? Yes, please.
Mr. Thompson, we're waiting.
My comments very brief. I just want to say I
am encouraged to see the increase in funding proposed for
street maintenance in the transportation and drainage operations budget,
but strong alert to the city to allocate sufficient funding to
ensure that our bike lanes are regularly cleaned and maintained,
ensuring that this critical transportation
in which the city and its partners have already made and committed a
significant investment, can continue to be used,
thereby increasing safety and accessibility for all transportation
modes. Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Thompson. Go ahead,
Mr. Smith. Good morning.
I have two quick comments. First of all, congratulations to the Department.
If you look at page 958 of the report,
their performance statistics with the Metro funds is fantastic.
It's the best of any department that I've seen, and they deserve
credit for that. And I'd like to ask one question. We provide
water to entities outside the city. This is a valuable
commodity and getting more valuable every day. Can we charge
premium rates to those users to recognize
that value and give Houston citizens a break in their bills?
Unfortunately, I've asked that question many times, and the answer to that is
no, we cannot. Why?
We're required by state.
Okay, that answers it. Thank you.
Next speaker is Mr. That's all,
Joseph. Katufro.
Good morning. Can you hear me okay? Yes, sir. Thank you. Sorry for butchering your
name. It's all right. Happens every day.
Good morning. My name is Joe Kutrufo, and I'm the Executive Director of Bike Houston,
a nonprofit organization working to transform Houston into a
city where anyone can get around safely and easily by
bike. Like Mr. Thompson, I'm here to express support
for the Houston Bikeways Maintenance program. Houston's bike
network is critical transportation infrastructure and it's time to start maintaining it
as such. And it's no secret to anyone, including some people in this
room who ride bikes around our city that are protected by leaves,
litter, broken glass. I even came across the aftermath of
car crash and found the whole front end of a Honda in the bike lane
one time. This is the number one complaint that Bike Houston hears about
from people who ride bikes and in fact, some folks in this
room. Council members Alcorn Robinson, we saw the debris piling
up in the WA and Commonwealth bike lanes. Council member Pollard,
you may remember the garbage we saw in the new bike lanes on Hillcroft.
Council member Cesneros knows all too well about the debris in the bike lanes
on Hardy Street. And Council member Kubosh could spend a lot less on repairs at
Blue Line Bike Lab if our bikeways were better maintained.
And nobody likes a flat tire, of course. But when we fail to clear debris
out of our bikeways, we create a safety hazard too. Because when
the lanes are full of debris, people opt to ride outside of the bike lanes,
entirely defeating the purpose of the bike lanes. We've invested so much
in building Houston's amazing bike network. And we're going to celebrate these investments
on Friday at the City's Bike to Work Day. But we can't stop at
just building the lanes. We have to do the fiscally responsible thing and maintain them
too. Our bike network. Mr. Katrufo, I'll let you go
longer than a minute. Can you wrap it up in 5 seconds? I do.
Friday. We have to make sure it's useful and safe. And if we're serious about
being a multimodal city where people have real transportation options other
than driving, we need to make sure the bike lanes are useful and
safe. Thank you. Thank you very much. Mr. Kurtrufo.
Just to make sure we don't have Jason Oliver, Aris Brown or Vicky
Martin on virtually.
And you are? Okay. Jason,
come on. We'll go through the list. Next we
have Saba Blanding no,
we'll call you in a minute. Yes,
sir. 1 minute. Just a reminder. Got it? Yes, sir.
Hi. I'm Jason Oliver. I live in District G.
Few questions I'm interested in. Oh perfect.
That's helpful. Thank you.
So I was tall too, so this works. Well,
I see that you all completed 74 council district service from
projects, which is great. People often mention how long it
takes to implement CDSF projects. I'm interested in what can
we do to speed up the implementation. Kind of going along with what
Council member Thomas said. And I'm also interested on page 29,
if you can explain how much is being transferred through
these 380 agreements specifically and then to which entities
are receiving those which entities are receiving those funds.
Thank you.
Hold on 1 second.
Any comments to
answer the previous question for a 380 agreement is about 4.1 million.
4.1. Yes. Okay, thank you.
Debt service. Correct.
Got it.
You are Saba Blanding? Yes. Okay.
Hi, I'm saba Blanding District I i had two questions
over the past seven years. I noticed that your department has seen fluctuations in
your budget for year to year, increasing as much as 9.8%
and decreasing as much as 19%. How have
these annual fluctuations impacted your department's ability
to plan for and provide adequate services to meet the needs of
the city of Houston? I thought it was really interesting how much it fluctuated.
And secondly, on slide 14, you said that more infrastructure
is degrading due to deferred, maintenance and insufficient
reinvestment. What type of investment do you need to see
from the city of Houston in order for your department to address Houston's
infrastructure needs in a timely manner?
So fluctuation in budget and then the second part
yeah, it just goes back to so some
of this fluctuation in budget over previous years has actually been rollover
of capital equipment. Our vehicles are replacing our dump trucks.
Very large expenditures that transfer from year to year in the operations budget.
On the capital investment side, what we're seeing is actually the result of
decades of underinvestment that we can't
maintain to keep it in useful life when something's 50, 60, 70 years
old. And so that statement is really referring to the fact that we
have increased build. Use of forward is increasing the reinvestment
and reconstruction. But there are things that are because every year
we go along, things are continuing to age that continue to get
beyond that. The water and wastewater system, the water rate study that we did
last year will have a significant reinvestment in the water and
wastewater system as a result of those rates.
Thank you. Diane Crest.
Diane Cress.
Doug, turn your camera off. We love you, but we don't love you
that much. Diane Cress.
Diane Cress.
Brown. Doris Brown.
Okay, keep going.
Becky Seal. I'm sorry. You, miss Brown.
My apologies. Come on forward. We'll have Ms.
Doris Brown followed missed by Miss Becky Seal.
My name is Doris Brown, and I'd like to address the historic
disinvestment in our bipartisan neighborhoods.
For years,
we have lived with the threat of flooding.
It has come to the point to where we are anxious when it start to
rain.
Excuse me? It has come to the point when we get anxious and
we get varied. It's kind of like post traumatic
distress. When it rains, we get anxious.
We get scared because we know that our streets are going to
hold water. We have been
historically disinvested and disenfranchised.
We would like to have an amendment for the public works to
have more money so they could do something about the flooding in our bipartisan
neighborhoods. Not only that, we want to address the
worst first. We would like for someone to come out to our neighborhoods
and start doing some work that alleviate the flooding that's going on.
I'll give you another couple of seconds. Could you define
your neighborhood? My neighborhood is City
Gas Lakewood. The northeast neighborhood. Got it.
District B, we have 88% of
open dish drainage, and we
just need some help out there. We need some infrastructure because the infrastructure is
antiquated, right? Yes. We're the worst
first. Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you. Yes, ma'am. Ms.
Brown.
Ms. Brown. Ms. Brown. Thank council Member Jackson. Thank you,
Ms. Brown, for coming in and for your group,
for all the work that you guys been doing in the district to make sure
that we get the resources and get the projects we need to
mitigate the flooding within District B. The neighborhoods
are the Northeast, Houston. You have cashmere? Garden, Fifth Ward Acres
Homes. And so these are neighborhoods that's hit hard every
flood. 88% of the open ditches are in our
district. That was a ditch study conducted back in 2014
out of the Hurricane Ike Disaster Recovery Round $2 that
indicated that we needed some investment within our neighborhoods.
And so I assure you that it's my priority. I will be submitting amendment to
make sure that we get the resources, some dollars allocated
for ditch maintenance, because if our ditches are not and our drainages are not
maintenance, that's what causes a lot of the flooding. And we can't depend
on seniors to do something that we should be
doing. We were doing it at one point. That changed in 2001.
And so I'm going to make sure that
we try to get a drainage schedule maintenance regularly within
our district. So thank you all for your advocacy. Thank you.
Thank you. Ms. Becky Seal.
Morning. Hey, good morning.
I'm Becky Seal with the Northeast Action Collective. And Doris and
all these people talking that packet we just passed out to you kind
of, like, elaborates a bit on why we're working with Tarsha
to do this budget amendment and really the details of what we're talking about.
So I heard you guys say that there is money
for drainage maintenance right now, and we'd like to know if that's different than
previous years, because the maintenance to this point really
is not matching the need at all. And if so
or regardless, where can the public see a schedule so that we can
keep public works accountable to that? So let me ask this question.
So we're dealing with general fund right now. I think that's dealing with
capital improvement project dollars. So two different things.
We will attack CIP probably next month or
so. So if an amendment comes forward within the general fund,
there has to be a correspondent debit that
you take away from it and a funding source that's identified.
And Council Member Jackson will probably submit that as well with her
amendment. But we will take up CIP.
Am I correct in that? Well, it's both. So there
is an O and M component to this. And I
do want to clarify, and I hope you will acknowledge that
Veronica Davis and her team have been very actively engaged with
this community over the last year and have worked with you to
identify specific locations.
We have actually done surveys of the roadside ditches
throughout the area, and we've identified, I believe,
25 different projects that we'll be doing over the next
18 months in that area that are in our budget that
are funded to be done. And so I want to make sure that
it's clear that we have responded to, that we
are actively but that's just the first step. Those are the ones
that you all have identified that, you know,
we're looking at the entire area out there and working to
identify those improvements. So we've also done
the maintenance through the entire area of everything that has been
identified to us. And there's a difference between true
maintenance, where it's actually going out, and removing
silt and soil and things in those ditches and restoring culverts versus
day to day, like, I take care of my
house, which is making sure that the litter is not getting there,
and things of that nature throughout
the city. What we ask people to do is that
light level maintenance, not that heavy
maintenance that we do. So we've
been working with Veronica Davis a lot. Right. And what she's told
us is that the money that they have to do proactive
maintenance is not nearly enough, that it's 500 miles of
open ditch drainage throughout the entire city per year. And she has said,
unless we have more money put aside for this, we cannot do
the maintenance required. And we don't think that the only ditches that should
be maintained is from a group of us who semi professionally
come to city council and have to put our entire lives into identifying ditches.
Yes, there's been a massive improvement, and it's been amazing to work with Veronica
Davis. We've really liked working with her and appreciated the response.
But we think that there has to be a shift from that pattern to
being more proactive. And she specifically has said the only
way that's possible is if there's more money specifically put for
that. Yes. And Miss Seal, if you want to look
up the CIP map that we have,
it can be found@buildhoustonforward.org.
And you'll see the CIP. Yeah, we've looked at it a lot. But the CIP
projects is not what we're talking about. We're not talking there are two
buckets of projects. One is general fund and one in CIP.
So we'll get to CIP, but your general fund.
Okay. But in either one, you can't see what the actual
money for ditch maintenance is. And we've scoured the Internet. If it's
out there, please send it to us. We're trying to see if there's money in
one of those overall city line
in the CIP budget that's going to ditch maintenance.
What does that mean? And then in the general fund, same thing.
So that we can if it's already happening spectacular,
we just want to see it and understand. Council member Tiffany Thomas.
Thank you. In addition to the budget amendment your
council member is going to offer, last year council Member Peck,
during budget last year authored an amendment for council
members to leverage council district service funds
to maintain open ditches in our district.
And I know she's had some successes with that. So in
addition to that, your council member can couple the work around the timeline
and the schedule that you're requesting, but then also leveraging some
of the dollars she has locally to make sure that the funding
that TDO is limited. To do that, the council office
can support. That's been great, and you talk too,
but Ms. Jackson has done a lot with that.
But that statistic Doris pointed out, 88% of open ditch
maintenance is in non white and
poor neighborhoods, basically. So every city district
having some money to put to that doesn't nearly address the problem.
It's an unequal problem. So there has to be what
I'm clarifying is that you have additional method.
So it's and in both. So in addition to what's showing up in the general
fund and the budget amendment for a timeline, she actually all of
us have dollars available to support that where TDO
is limited. So it's and in both. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you, Miss Sale. Next, we have Ms. Carolyn Addison
Rivera.
Good morning. What you see here are recent
pictures of the ditches
that we live in and the contamination
that we deal with with water and
our land. The first thing I want to do is say
thank you. Okay. The first thing I want
thank you, sir. Yes, ma'am. The first thing I want
to do is say thank you to the city council and
to let you know that we need you.
We cannot. This is recent. If you can see this,
this is what we live with every
day. I have been calling Veronica
Davis and the rest of since 2014,
pleading for help. I've lived in that community
over 40 years. When I moved there,
there was regular maintenance. We had no
flooding. My children could play.
This was not in our community. This is
reason. Just yesterday, I called
and the guy come out, asked me, what do I want him to do?
They dig ditches. Well water. Just stand.
Do you hear me? It just stand. Thank you.
Thank you. Ms. Addison Rivera. Thank you. And thank you very
much. We need you. We can't do it without you.
This is it reason. Thank you,
ma'am. Appreciate it. Leah Johnson.
Leah Johnson.
Benjamin Broadway.
Thank American.
Mr. Broadway. Morning, sir.
There you go. We're good. Okay. Thank you.
I'm going to get straight to the point. In the Northeast,
we need sewage and
runoff. Help our kids stand
in water when they're waiting for the school bus.
Do your kids wait and stand in water?
They get to school soaking wet.
We need flood help in our area.
We need the covered ditches. Three,
one, one is a joke to me
because when I call for help, they have us
register. Every year, every time we move, when the disabled
and visually impaired people relocate, they ask us
to register. I register. I've never gotten one
call from three one one to say, hello. Mr.
Broadway. Are you okay? Do you need to evacuate?
My family has had to come in high water vehicles to
come and get me from my home. So please,
with your help help. District B,
I'm in Lakewood. I'm one of many disabled
people that need the help.
Thank you, Mr. Broadway, would you like a couple of seconds of my time
to complete your statement? Yes.
If there's any way we can try and make
the system better, because every time we call
with even simple things of loose animals
because I can't walk to my mailbox without trying to get attacked
by a dog,
and the flooding issues, here I am facing
another hurricane season. I'm terrified from a small
rain. I don't know if my area is
going to flood because the covered ditches, they have so
much in them. Thank you. Council member Tasha Jackson.
I just wanted to thank them for coming in and sharing their concerns.
And then also just to piggyback on what Director Haddock did
say about the SWAT projects slated for the area,
and we doing the H and H studies. I think we just completed the
H and H studies to actually show why these particular
neighborhoods are draining. I mean, it's true that there has been no investment,
why these neighborhoods are flooding. There has been no investment. And now we
are getting the studies to identify why these neighborhoods are
flooding. And then the next round is the fixing,
the mitigating, these flooding. I mean, we have train tracks. We're always talking
about the trains that's contributing to a lot of the flooding. So I just
want to assure you that there has been a lot of movement and we're
doing a lot of work. We had a lot of projects slated for the
district to address the flooding. But then also, we do need
a ditch maintenance schedule. So I'm with you on that.
And, of course, Director Haddock said there's resources already in
this budget for that. And so I'm going to have further conversations just to identify
what is the amount, how much do it cost. If I have to use some
of my district service funds, I will use some of my district service
funds, but I have to use for parks and the illegal dumping
and all these other things. So a million dollars only goes so far.
So I want to try to work with the departments and see if we can
find resources to move some of these projects. So thank you again for coming.
Thank you. Thank you, Chair, and thank you, sir, for coming. This question
is for the Public Works Director. So the document they provided,
it said prior to 2001, we did regular maintenance.
The city did regular maintenance of roadside ditches.
And now we just go based on three one on complaints.
Did the city ever have a policy where we regularly maintained,
I'll be honest with you, council Member, I do not know the answer to that
question. I'm going to have to get with and Eric Dargan joined
the city in 2002. I joined in
2005.
I'm unaware of that. But I also do know that there
were a lot of things that in the late ninety s and early
2000s, because of the limitations on
the general fund, which at the time was in the general fund,
were not able to continue forward. So I do not know the answer to that
question because I've always been under the impression we did more
major regrading and things like that on a regular schedule.
But the maintenance itself, like the mowing, I mean, these pictures
are way more than just mowing needed. I mean, that's a different situation.
But that was the property owner's responsibility. Thank you.
Malberth Moses.
Good morning.
I don't understand why I'm have to come up here and fight for what's
supposed to be our rights in the first place.
I moved in my neighborhood over 50
years ago and it was predominantly white neighborhood. I couldn't
even go outside the plate till you choose because being
attacked. But they had a regular schedule
of keeping up the ditch maintenance, picking up the heavy
trash. But then as the neighborhood began to
grow more black
and brown, all of a sudden this stopped.
And I don't see why all stopped all of
a sudden. Why we just got took off the schedule altogether.
I haven't seen anybody come in that neighborhood in over 20 years
to clean the ditches. And that's ridiculous
because we deserve that, right?
So can somebody answer that question? Why do I have
to come up here and fight for a right that I already deserve? Thank you,
Mr. Moses. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
I'm sorry. Thank you.
I'm sorry. Vice chair, Ed Pollard. Thank you
sir, for coming in. Your comment, this is
for public Works. When you all are going out and identifying projects
and infrastructure needs for improvements to the drainage,
or is there some type of list
that you all have put together to
be able to understand what are the drainage and infrastructure
needs for that particular area? Has that
been shared to the public? Do we have a cost estimate for
some of those improvements so that we as council can be better abreast
on what could be done to alleviate
some of these issues? That the community I will interject.
Each district gets $2 million in SWAT projects designated by
their council members. I know we do that. And every other district receives
2 million in SWAT projects. I'm not sure where your neighbor is
on the District B project list, but we do have
the ability to do that what I'm speaking of is just general,
not swap projects because those are smaller, like 2 million
a year projects. What I'm saying is like an overall high level view
of infrastructure needs when it pertains
to drainage and maintenance for an area like District B that has
a lot of open ditches. So I may
ask Veronica to come up and join us, but it's
been in the last decade through this administration that we've
actually gone out and surveyed Ditches Citywide to have an idea on
what the capacity of those ditches are. And we're
currently working on a condition assessment for Ditches Citywide,
which would give us more of that answer. We did have from the
late 90s, early two thousand s, a capacity
assessment of the Pipe Systems Citywide. And so this is
that data driving. And so to be more
proactive, you have to have that citywide data.
In lieu of having that data. We did rely a lot
on the three one one reports, and that's what we're working with the
council member right now. When would the
data be available for you all to do an assessment?
Good morning, everyone. Well, good afternoon at this point. So.
Veronica Davis, director of Transportation and Drainage operations in Houston
Public Works. So one, we're working on our stormwater master
plan. So the city up until now has never had a full master plan.
So currently, right now, we should be going to a notice
to proceed very soon. And so there'll be a couple of components
with that. So part of it will be doing an H and H
hydraulics analysis for the city to be able to understand these
needs, and then two, to be able to think about what
is the full need that we have for the city. We have
have other plans that have been done that we will pull into this process
to help inform some of that. And I also want to clarify what
we do generally, we do rely on three one one right
now for digit maintenance. And so we do send our digital maintenance crews
out to do the regrading to do the desilting. Once it is
beyond the ability of our internal crews to do, we do refer
it to either SWAT, which we work with the council members on.
We also have the local drainage program. And so we have been working with
the Northeast Action Collective. We have projects right now that are indesigned.
We do our design in house. So we are currently working on projects
that are indesigned. And in the new fiscal year, we'll be going to construction
to address some of the concerns that have been brought up by the collective.
Thank you, Ms. Davis. Thank you, Mr. Moses.
Council Member David Robinson. I'm sorry, this one was with Mr.
Moses in mind, but basically a comment wanting to
thank the Northeast Action Collective for being here.
I think in addition to what we just heard from Ms. Davis and the director.
I think there are some really positive trends.
This is slow coming. And your patience and observations
in the neighborhood, we understand why that's a grievance, why that's
not fair and not right and not satisfactory. So I think moving forward,
what we've heard today are some of the very progressive actions
that are being taken. They need to happen faster, in my opinion.
And part of what we're doing together, with your input, with your
group and with some of the tools that the Director mentioned
is detect problems sooner, work on them
more proactively, with an inventory of those ditches,
those pipes, and where we can be more effective
and more fair, more equitable with our dollars. And working
across this huge city, But I think the literature that
you all have brought today is really well done. It's compelling,
it's instructive, and it points a path to where
the worst first can be prioritized. So I want to salute you,
Mr. Moses, and thank you for coming today. Thank you.
James Burford.
James Burford. Got you.
Sandra Edwards.
Good morning, everybody. I'm not
going to even hold you all along because everything I want to say has been
said, has been said already. This is just
a map of the community in the neighborhood. I'm from I'm from two six.
Okay, the council closed and all that good stuff. Okay, I just want
to say one thing. You all need to put first things first. I know you
all been hearing all this and I know you're tired of hearing all this because
we're tired of saying it, but can you all put first things first?
We didn't showed you the proof. That what we need. It's not like we're asking
for it because this is just we feel we better. They think they better because
they get everything that needs to come their way. For you to come to our
area, can you put first things first? Come to our area, do some cleanup,
clean some drainages. Maybe we won't flood so much and
stop these people from going against us, our communities,
and bringing in stuff that's going to make us flood,
stopping up our drainages and everything. Just do the
right thing for once. That's all I got to say. Do something right for
a change. Thank you. Julia arduna.
Julia Arduna.
Anil Kapoor.
Okay, thank you, council people,
for having us come in today to speak and giving us
a chance to speak. Before I talk, I do want
to express my gratitude to Veronica Davis and her
department. In a little less than a year, her and
her office have been way more impactful for our neighborhood
and our collective and the residents that have been there for over 20 years
than any of the previous people in her position.
Also want to thank Tasha Jackson for being open and working with us
as well and being accessible.
I just want to read this prepared statement.
We would love for the city council to amend a
public works budget to include a pilot program for drainage maintenance
in district B. Specifically, it is one of the most flood prone areas
and has very high concentrations of BIPOC and LMI
people, as well as public housing. Open ditch drainage is an example
of separate and unequal that leaves our communities vulnerable.
It's essential that we invest before the next hurricane and disaster.
Our seal thank you. Supposed to rise 18 inches. Thank you, sir. Thank you.
Appreciate it. David espinoza.
Have Mr. Espinoza, then followed by Mr. Butler, and that will
conclude the public speakers. Mr. Espinoza.
Good afternoon. My name is David. I'm from district b.
I want to say that I used to be in
just about the same predicament as my colleagues in the NAC.
About a half a year ago, there was some development
right along little York and epson road.
And around the same time, there was also commercial
development. There was a couple of fast food places going up.
And at the same time, there was a road maintenance,
which came along with ditch maintenance.
And my family saw a dramatic improvement
from the flooding we got we used to have
we couldn't get out of our neighborhood when it when it was flooded real bad.
But that's proof that ditch maintenance
widening ditches, making them deeper, cleaning them out,
it's not regular, but we do our best to keep
our trash out, me and my neighbors,
and so far, we've been doing good so far,
and I want to see that happening throughout the northeast with my fellow
members, to see them live better. Thank you, Mr.
Espinoza. Thank you, Mr.
Butler.
You're the last one we can say good morning to, so we will. Good morning.
Good afternoon.
My name is Broderick Butler, and I'm a resident of district b.
Those are my neighbors, and our message is pretty consistent.
Along with getting things done faster, we'd like for things to
be done properly and consistently.
Council member Robinson, with all due respect,
this is the first time I'm hearing these staff names, and I've long since
wanted the senior management to
come to our district and talk to people on their level
about a problem that you've heard from
multiple people over a period of decades.
So my questions directed to the director are,
who makes the decision where money is spent in their department in regards
to our district and infrastructure projects?
I also want to know, again this question of scheduling.
There are people that have lived in this community their entire lives, and they've seen
things go away. They're not lying to you.
Lastly, there's a water treatment plant. There's still a disconnect there's
a water treatment plant that was created in the northeast.
No one knows it even exists that lives in the northeast.
So I would say to you, this department,
while it has done a lot of good for us,
we need some more reaching out to this community
to talk about solving the problems that exist.
Thank you. Thank you. And I have some additional questions that
I'd like to submit in writing.
We will put those into SharePoint. That concludes
the Houston Public Works Budget workshop. Thank you,
Director Haddock. Thank you,
Director Salanki. Appreciate your insight.